hi everybody so um thank you for joining
us for today's presentation
entitled single nucleus and spatial
transcriptomics
of archival pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma
after neoadjuvant treatment and it's my
real pleasure to introduce you to
william huang
he's a really fantastic young scientist
based in boston he's the holman research
fellow at the broad institute and the
koch institute for integrated cancer
research he's a resident physician in
the harvard radiation oncology program
at mass general
and dana farber cancer institute the
brigham and women's hospital and the
boston children's hospital
and for a complete biography of william
and all our speakers you can visit the
tab
at the bottom of your screen now if you
have any questions during the
presentation
please submit them in the q a box and
our speaker will respond back to you
via email so please join me in welcoming
william
i'll turn the presentation over to him
hi my name is william huang and i'm a
research fellow at the broad institute
of harvard and mit
and mass general hospital i'm excited to
be here today to share with you
our work on single nucleus and spatial
transcriptomics
of pancreatic cancer after a new
adjuvant treatment
i have no financial disclosures
so pancreatic cancer remains one of the
deadliest solid tumors
despite several decades of concerted
research efforts
clinical outcomes have not improved
significantly as you can see from the
annually updated
cancer statistics in the united states
on the top left
in men and women the incidence of
pancreatic cancer
is only approximately 10th but
the estimated deaths attributed to
pancreatic cancer currently ranks fourth
and is projected to be the number two
cause of cancer death by 2030. and a
large reason for this is that the
other cancers ahead of pancreatic cancer
have seen some significant improvements
in therapeutic options and outcomes over
the past several years
whereas even for localized surgically
resectable pancreatic cancer the
five-year survival is only approximately
30 percent and if you are diagnosed with
metastatic disease
uh the five-year survival is only a
dismal three percent
so as with a lot of other cancers there
is an interest
in improving uh precision oncology for
pancreatic cancer
and the first place people turned to was
looking at
what somatic mutations could tell us
about
a person's particular type of pancreatic
cancer
unfortunately in one large study of
long-term survivors of pancreatic cancer
compared to
those that had a more typical survival
duration
exome sequencing didn't reveal any
significant differences in the somatic
mutation profiles among
these very disparate patient groups
furthermore comparing primary and
metastatic tumors
shows a pretty limited mutational
heterogeneity suggesting that
non-genetic mechanisms may actually be
the predominant source of clinical
variation
so as with some other cancers
researchers in the pancreatic cancer
field turned
to looking at gene expression and in
particular
doing transcriptomics in bulk
of pancreatic specimens generally in the
treatment naive
setting and there were three major
efforts over the last decade by
collision bailly moffett and colleagues
where
they looked at primary
pancreatic tumors and they did
unsupervised clustering
of their rna profiles to try to
understand
what subtypes might distinguish the
clinical variation seen in patients and
there were two widely considered tumor
intrinsic
profiles known as the basal like or
squamous profile
and the classical progenitor profile
that are
considered to be tumor intrinsic and
then in addition there are some other
subtypes that have been identified such
as the exocrine or the immunogenic
that have subsequently been found to be
likely
driven by stromal contamination part of
the problem and the reason we're seeing
this with the bulk
transcriptomic data is because despite
the aggressiveness of pdac
the malignant cells can be in the
vast minority of actual cells that
compose a tumor in fact
in some pancreatic tumors we see single
digit percentages of the neoplastic
cellularity
most of the rest of the tumor is
composed of various stromal components
so these these various bulk efforts
actually tried to address this by either
enriching
for epithelial content by selecting
specimens
with more than 40 epithelial content
or by performing micro dissection
and both of these lead to biases uh in
the
in the resulting data so this seems like
the perfect
setup to move into the single cell rna
sequencing
uh realm that has uh really provided
additional insights
in numerous cancers to date the problem
with efforts in singles rna-seq for
pancreatic cancer is largely two-fold
however
the first is the fact that these tumors
are very desmond plastic
and therefore dissociating tumors into a
single cell suspension is very difficult
and the more you dissociate the more you
compromise viability so that trade-off
has become a big problem for pancreatic
cancer
the second issue is that the pancreas
normal role is
largely a digestive role protein pro
proteases rnases other digestive enzymes
are replete in pancreatic tissue
so when you're trying to maintain rna
integrity for an rna-seq readout
that becomes also very problematic so we
attempted to
address these challenges by developing
and optimizing
a single nucleus rather than single cell
rna-seq approach which we call snoop
seek
which is useful in several regards first
you don't have as many problems with the
digestive enzymes because the
specimens are snap frozen and they're
when they thaw
for processing the whole process only
takes about 10 minutes from
beginning to end in terms of extracting
the nuclei and separating the rnas of
interest
from the digestive enzymes the second
benefit
of this is that dissociation becomes
much less of a problem because you don't
need to maintain cell viability
and then the last potentially largest
advantage of
snook seek over a single serena seek is
that you don't need fresh specimens
so we're able to take archival frozen
specimens that were
stored for a different purpose many many
years ago and actually
obtain very high quality single nucleus
rna-seq data from them
at the present time so this workflow
summarizes uh to date the 27 specimens
that we have
uh processed about 50 are treatment
naive
and fifty percent uh have undergone
neoadjuvant chemo radiation and these
are all surgical specimens
that we're working with and we split the
specimens for snook seek and then a
subset for bulk rna-seq
um a multiplex ion beam imaging um as
well as
nanostring digital spatial profiling um
and what we've noticed empirically is
that
an rna integrity number um using the
agilent bioanalyzer
platform of greater than six seems to be
necessary in order to
have sufficient rna integrity for good
downstream snook seek
data so this slide summarizes the
15 patients in the treatment naive
cohort
you can see there's a broad range of
ages of genders
of a stage grade margin status a few of
them have the
more rare adnosquamas histology
and then also a pretty broad range in
terms of adjuvant treatment and clinical
outcomes
for the 12 neoadjuvant treated patients
we have a similar range
in terms of their clinical pathologic
features a couple of the patients had
brocco ii germline
mutations and all these patients got
neoadjuvant uh
radiotherapy the majority got falfirinox
uh as well um and then uh two patients
got nivolumab or losartan on trial
so we processed all these
these 27 specimens through our pipeline
and
we yielded after filtering quality
control
about 170 000 nuclei across the 27
patients
and we performed community detection
using a leiden algorithm
and we were able to identify distinct
cell populations
using known cell type specific gene
expression signatures
and you can see at the each of these
boxes is a umap for an individual
patient
naive on the left treated on the right
and the gray
cell clusters represent the tumor cells
the malignant cells
and then the various colored clusters
represent different
types of non-malignant cells including
acinar ductal endocrine endothelial
fibroblast immune
schwann and smooth muscle so all the
major cell types we were able to
identify with confidence
from the transcriptomic profiles in our
nuclei
on the bottom right those stack
proportion bar plots
are illustrating at an individual
patient level the wide range
of cell type distributions in the naive
and treated settings
so to further increase our confidence in
calling the malignant cells within our
tumors we performed inferred copy number
variation
analysis so this is just one example
patient and on the top
of this uh of this plot
basically across all the chromosomes
you're looking at the inferred copy
number variations by
a sliding window of 100 genes the
expression of 100 genes sliding along
each chromosome arm
and trying to see if they're
concordantly enriched or depleted
and inferring copy number variations
from that so on the top
this is from the normal adjacent
pancreatic tissue
from one of our tumors and you can see
there are really no
patterns suggesting cnb clonality
and then on the bottom this is the
actual tumor itself
so some are don't have any cmvs
and are likely non-malignant cell types
and then you can see
some distinct clusters marked in gray on
the left
that correspond to our malignant cells
where you see a very
distinct cnb pattern and then to
as a gut check we wanted to see since we
only had 27 patients
were the cmvs that we were inferring
from our 27 patients were those
representative pancreatic cancer
patients overall
so we for this we turn to uh the tcga
cohort of about 180 some patients
where they use snip and whole exome
sequencing to determine arm level
somatic copy number variations so
in the plot on the right i'm showing the
cnb proportion
relative to the chromosome arm and dark
blue is our snook seek data and light
blue is the tcga cohort and
in gray is a different cancer altogether
that's prostate cancer
so as you can see there is a pretty
close association between the
proportions
of cmvs that we saw in our data compared
to ccga
and very distinct from the prostate
cancer data from tcga
so the next thing we wanted to do was to
to really test this hypothesis that
snook c gives us better representation
of the cell type proportions present in
the actual
tumor in situ compared to the uh
single cell rna-seq approaches that have
been tried prior to this
so for this to give us our kind of
histologic ground truth if you will
we use multiplex ion beam imaging we use
the panel
of about 27 different targets but what
i'm showing you here is the main
compartments of interest
so the images on the top on the left in
red that's cd45
on the right is cd 31 and then green
in both cases is keratin dark blue is
vitamin
and then cyan is the nuclear compartment
marked by
a double-stranded dna antibody
and on the bottom four panels we used a
software package
called histacat um to basically
uh create uh to segment and create masks
for each of these compartments
and then from that we were able to
enumerate the number of cells
across three different fields of view
per specimen
and then when we average those together
and compared it with the
cell type enumeration by snoop seek you
can see for the eight patients that we
did this side-by-side comparison for
some differences but for the most part a
pretty close correlation between
mimi and snook seek for the proportion
of endothelial immune
fibroblasts and epithelial cells um and
then on the bottom right those are two
summary
stacked bar plots naive on the left
treated on the right for all the
patients combined and you can again see
a pretty close correlation so this
confirmed our hypothesis that
um the processing involved with snook c
seems to be able to better capture the
um the cell type proportions present in
these tumors
so next we combined all of our um 170
000 or so nuclei in the treated and
treatment naive cohorts and
made combined umaps out of them so gray
again is tumor
um is the malignant part of the tumor i
should say
and you can see that um the tumor cells
are segregating by patient um
as expected whereas the non-malignant
cell types are
grouping together across patients
and you can also make a few kind of
initial
qualitative observations here there's
significantly more
malignant cells in the naive cohort
compared to the treated and there seems
to be an enrichment for some of the
non-neoplastic cell types which
is better shown in these this box plot
here um the asana the ductal
the endocrine fibroblast compartments
are all
enriched in the post-treatment cohort
whereas the tumor is significantly
depleted as you would expect
with some treatment response and the
increase in
the asner ductal endocrine etc uh
cell cell counts
after treatment uh is thought to be both
related to potentially direct
stimulation and regeneration
of normal pancreatic tissue with
treatment but also
a a known desmoplastic contracture of
the tissue after chemo radiation
that just simply increases the density
of
some of these normal cell types that are
relatively resistant to chemotherapy and
radiation
so this plot um is just to illustrate
that you know without dwelling too much
on the specific details
that you can we can zoom in to you know
the immune population
endocrine population and use uh further
uh
uh
known cell type signatures to refine
these
uh larger groups into um various immune
cell types or endocrine
cell types and from a pure enumeration
sample we see some interesting changes
with treatment
for example in the plot on the left you
can see that there's a significant
depletion of t regs post treatment and
then on the right
i'm breaking out just the dendritic
cells in
the treatment naive setting on the left
and the treated setting on the right
and you can see that there's a
significant increase in the classical
dendritic cell type 1 or cdc ones
with treatment and a significant
depletion in cdc2s
and this is uh so much the case that
we were not even able to reliably detect
any cdc2s
in the post-treatment setting and this
is interesting because there's some
preliminary data
from uh some clinical trials looking at
neoadjuvant chemo radiation and the
effects on the immune system
that suggest uh this same shift towards
a cdc-1
dendritic cell phenotype which is
associated with uh cross-presentation to
cytotoxic t cells
and more of an anti-tumor effect
compared to cdc tubes which are known
for their role
in immunosuppression wound healing etc
so to go beyond enumeration and
look at in detail what changes are
occurring with
treatment we did a differential
expression analysis comparing
post-treatment
specimens with treatment naive specimens
so in these seven volcano plots here
the right side of the plot represents
genes that are enriched
in the post-treatment setting on the
left genes that are enriched in the
treatment naive setting
so this is still an ongoing analysis at
this time so i'll just call your
attention to a few highlights that
were very robust findings so on the top
left
in gray this is the neoplastic
compartment and we found that
chemo radiation was associated with an
enrichment in type 1 and type 2
interferon response genes
but also a depletion in developmental
programs
previously associated with the classical
progenitor subtype in bulk
which the compass trial recently found
uh was more sensitive to cytotoxic
therapy compared to the basal squamous
subtype so
our data seems to be consistent with
those findings
uh amongst the immune cells um i'll call
your attention to the cd8 t cells which
are shown in lavender
on the middle row the right volcano plot
um so the treatment was associated with
upregulation of several activation
programs
uh such as il-7r tcf7 stat 4 and slam f6
which have been uh linked to
memory activation cell survival as well
as
response to checkpoint inhibitors and
other cancers such as melanoma
and concordantly there was a depletion
in the exhaustion markers tim3 and cd39
which again in melanoma has been
associated with a lack of response to
checkpoint inhibitors
so this was interesting to us because
while
checkpoint inhibitors have largely
failed in metastatic
pancreatic cancer except in the in the
one percent of patients
that have microsatellite instability um
these results seem to suggest that
perhaps there's a different
situation when you combine
or combine immune checkpoint inhibitors
with chemo radiation in the neoadjuvant
setting and certainly that's something
that several trials are currently
looking into and will be interesting to
see what those results are
and then finally on the bottom right in
that yellow
volcano plot those are the fibroblasts
and
after treatment there seemed to be this
enrichment for
a hyper-activated myofibroblastic
phenotype
so the next thing we wanted to do was
you know use this opportunity
where we have this uh almost 170 000
nuclei from 27 patient samples
we could really use this opportunity to
kind of go beyond the
basal classical distinction that has
been well established in the bulk
setting
and look at what other common gene
expression
themes are shared across multiple
patients and might have some bearing on
the biological behavior of this very
aggressive tumor
so without going into some of the
specific details because
we actually uh recently did a
re-analysis
of this topic modeling i want to make
the point that
we do see when we do topic modeling
across our patients
an endoderm progenitor and an epithelial
topic very consistently
and those are very similar to the
classical
and basal squamous subtypes identified
in bulk
we also confirmed findings by other
groups that
the same tumor will express we'll have
cells that express a predominantly
classical profile whereas others will
express a predominantly basal profile
and those
are heterogeneous within the same tumor
but beyond that we see
other topics that are also very
prevalent
zankabal neural progenitor etc and we're
in the process
of doing this topic modeling not just
for the tumor cells but also the
fibroblasts and other cell types
and really trying to learn what themes
may correlate
or predict outcomes in this disease
and then taking the what we learn at the
single nucleus single cell level
and using that information to deconvolve
bulk rna-seq data
that's much more readily available and
translatable into
future clinical trials so this slide is
just showing
that if you classify a patient's
individual cells based on the dominantly
expressed
tumor or fibroblast topic you can see
there's a broad range
in terms of the heterogeneity and
distribution of different topics within
each patient tumor
so we were able to learn a decent amount
and we're still learning stuff
with further analyses in the
dissociative setting but we're really
limited by the fact that the tumor has
been you know has lost all spatial
information at this point
and a lot of the a lot of the important
interactions between different cell
types or even between the same cell
types
can only be captured if you have a
spatial fidelity and resolution
so we partnered with nanastring to
use their digital spatial profiling
platform
known as geomics to help us get
transcriptomic information
that's spatially resolved and really
take the data to another level
so what i'm showing here is a schematic
of the nanostring workflow
for their geomix platform and there's
two very similar paths you can take it's
just different the difference is just
the probe
you can go after protein targets or rna
we mainly focus on rna
i'm using ish probes but you could very
easily do the exact same things
with antibodies so these antibody or
rna-ish probes have been tagged with a
barcode
that has a uv cleavable
linker that attaches them to the probe
and we start with an ffpe slide
from the clinic and we do all of our
standard processing
d-waxing engine retrieval etc and then
once everything has been processed we
stain that slide
using a combination of four morphology
markers to label the nuclear compartment
and three other
morphological compartments of interest
and then a probe set from nanostring
that covers your targets of interest and
then after you label that
you put the slide onto the device and
there's a slide scanner built in
and you scan it and you see the four
color immunofluorescence image
and you're able to then go in and choose
specific regions of interest
or within those regions of interest
areas of interest that you want to
interrogate further
then the digital micro mirror device um
that nanostring developed will customize
the illumination mask to fit whatever
your region of interest or area of
interest looks like and it'll actually
move the
move to that area of the slide
illuminate and photo cleave
all those barcodes in that area of
interest and then
those will get sucked up by the straw
and deposited into a spatially indexed
96 well plate
and depending on what plex your panel is
you can either read out that spatially
indexed transcriptomic information
on the encounter platform or with ngs
so with nanostring we first started with
their
cancer transcriptome atlas or cta panel
this is a carefully curated uh over 1500
rna target panel that was collated from
various other
you know well-established cancer
signatures that are listed here
and here are three of our samples that
we have performed this protocol
on i'm showing side-by-side images of
the
four color amino fluorescence and the
rois that we selected
next to an h e image um
and what we've labeled in green the
epithelial compartment
in magenta the immune compartment and in
cyan
the fibroblast compartment
so the question that we were really
interested in answering um
that requires spatial resolution is
within the same tumor we expected that
there would be regions
that were infiltrated by immune cells
and regions that were
uh exclusionary to immune cells and that
there may be
tumor intrinsic or potentially
fibroblast intrinsic
transcriptional programs that were in
part governing this local
immune micro environment and we wanted
to understand what that was
with the hopes that that would lead to
improvements in
immunotherapy strategies in this disease
so what i'm showing here
is the three different types of regions
of interest that we see across
most of our patients on the left this is
an example of
tumor cells that are surrounded by
fibroblasts in cyan as well as immune
cells in magenta
the middle panel shows tumor cells that
are only surrounded by fibroblasts and
then on the right these are tumor cells
only surrounded by
immune cells and no fibroblasts so the
nanostring
geometrics platform has really nice auto
segmentation feature built in where you
can control
some of the parameters like thresholding
and erosion factors
but ultimately you get really nice
segmentation as you can see here
see here where we actually went after
very complex
patterns um you know based on what our
tumors look like
to actually separate out the tumor the
immune and the fibroblast compartments
and interrogate them separately
uh within each roi so we collected our
data
and uh we because this was over
800 plex we had an ngs readout and we
took that data the first thing we wanted
to do
was to see how it compared to the snook
seq data so we actually took
these snook seeks signatures for various
cell types and we use those to
deconvolve
the nanostring data as you can see in
this heat map here
we got a very clear epithelial cluster
on the top
the the green rois represent epithelial
and you can see it really matches the
tumor signature
from snook c similarly for calves this
would be one two three four the fifth
the fifth row down
you can see there's a very clear
fibroblast signature that correlates
between the nanostring
and the snook seq data and then various
immune populations also correlated
very well so this really demonstrated
nicely the coherence and complementarity
of the nanostring platform and the the
single nucleus rna-seq
approach so next we wanted to compare
the differential expression patterns in
the tumor and fibroblast compartments by
treatment
in the nanostring data compared to the
snook seek data so here you're seeing a
volcano plot
where genes enriched in treated
tumor aois are on the right and genes
enriched in naive tumor aois are on the
left
and without going into the details since
this is just a preliminary analysis i'm
showing you here
a lot of the initial genes that we're
seeing
are comparable between the two platforms
for both the tumor
and the fibroblasts which was very
reassuring to see
so moving into the spatial realm further
we used our data to ask the question
what genes are differentially expressed
in the tumor compartment
based on whether or not the roi is
infiltrated by immune cells or not
and we were able to
get pretty robust signatures from this
that we're still currently exploring
but this is data that we could only get
with spatial resolution and not with the
dissociated data
so we're really excited to explore this
further
and then we can also do something very
similar with the calf compartment
uh to try to derive fibroblast intrinsic
programs that may
govern the immune infiltration in the
local environment
so with topic modeling i mentioned
earlier that
we were able to move beyond the
traditional classical versus basal
distinction
and really look at a whole host
of themes that various tumor cells
within a
within a pancreatic cancer use to
potentially gain the fitness advantage
and
collaborate um for that goal and
from a very initial look you know we
only have 1500 or so genes in
in the cta which is a lot of genes
except when you're looking at the topics
those are derived from the whole
transcriptome so
quite a bit of imputation has to occur
because they're not all represented
in the cta panel but even with that
limitation
when you look for example across the
eight
topics that we identified in the cancer
cells
um we found some interesting
associations for example
the mesenchymal topic
was strongly associated with rois that
contained fibroblasts and then
looking at it in a different way we
found that the endoderm progenitor
um which is similar to the bulk
classical subtype
was associated with immune infiltration
more than other topics so these are
things that we're currently exploring
more
but certainly yielding some interesting
results already
so to address you know this limitation
as well as
um as well as really open the doors to a
lot of other potentially interesting
questions
nanostring has recently developed a
whole transcriptome
assay that is really
changing the way we're able to do this
analysis because we no longer have to
impute
certain genes in our topic signatures we
now have all the genes
available and we did a preliminary
analysis with them
that so far is showing some exciting
early results
so this is the four color
immunofluorescence from the
nanostring geomix platform and you can
see some example rois
that are that are overlaid on the image
and we found that across the
transcriptome we were able to
successfully detect 6600 genes spatially
with it with our samples and this is
without optimization just a very initial
pilot
and what i'm showing here is these in
these droid plots
the top 3 330
most highly expressed targets by segment
and the colors correspond to what we've
been using so cyan
represents the fibroblasts magenta is
the immune
and green is the epithelial and
to see if we're on the right track if
you zoom in on
one example fibroblast aoi
you can see that the scores after
deconvolving for our topics
are much higher for the fibroblast topic
compared to the tumor topics
for this fiberglass aoi and conversely
for the epithelial aoi
the tumor topics are much more highly
expressed in the fibroblast topics
so this was consistent you know with
what we would expect
and suggest that uh suggests that the
data is um
is is going to be very useful um as we
move forward
so we're very excited at this point you
know with the
preliminary data that we have that
between the
the better understanding of pancreatic
cancer molecular taxonomy
as well as more insights gained
looking at the effects of neoadjuvant
chemoradiation and other treatments
we're really going to be able to move
forward
with the spatially resolved technology
and start to understand the interplay
between
various components of these pancreatic
tumors and ultimately
be able to inform precision oncology and
pancreatic cancer
in a much more meaningful way so thank
you very much for
your attention i hope you found the
presentation useful
i'd like to thank several people without
whom none of this work would have been
possible
first and foremost my postdoctoral
advisors aviv regev
at the broad and tyler jacks at the koch
institute
um very close collaborators which who
have contributed to
every part of what i've shown you today
are karthik yagadish
a computational biologist in the regev
lab jimmy guo a ucsf md phd student
and hannah hoffman a research technician
working closely with me
i'd also like to express my gratitude to
my collaborators
at mgh brigham and dana farber
especially andy lists carlos fernandez
and mari mino
for the clinical side of this project
and then also my close collaborators at
nanastring um
dan zonger kit fuhrman and jason reeves
for all their help and then last but not
least um the funding agencies that have
made this work possible
um have been the lust garden foundation
and the
cancer foundation of asco thank you
you